تهديد النووي الايرانيه يستنفر اسرائيل
التي قد تسرع في توجيه ضربه الى طهران
فالتطورات الاخيره التي طفت على السطح قد
تدفع تل ابيب الى تنفيذ هجوم على طهران
سيما وان الاخيره تفكر في الحصول على
انظمه دفاع جوي الخبر كشفت عنه وكاله
بلومبرج التي ذكرت ان ايران تسعى للحصول
على منظومه الدفاع الجوي الروسيه اس 400
خطوه قد تؤدي الى تسريع خططي تل ابيب في
توجيه ضربه محتمله لبرنامج طهران النووي
فحصول طهران على هذه الانظمه سيسمح لها
بالتصدي للهجمات الصاروخيه وهو ما يدفع
اسرائيل الى التعجيل في تنفيذ ضربتها
وحصول ايران على انظمه الدفاع الجوي
الروسيه لم يتم تاكيدها كما كان متوقعا في
روسيا لم تصرح بشكل علني اذا ما كانت
ستزود ايران بالاسلحه رغم الاتهامات
الغربيه المستمره لها بالتعاون العسكري مع
طهران وتاتي كل هذه التطورات في وقت يزداد
فيه القلق بشان الخطوات النوويه الايرانيه
منذ ان عثر مراقبون وكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه على يورانيوم مخصب بنسبه 84% وهي
نسبه اقل بقليل من التسعين بالمئه اللازمه
لتصنيع السلاح النووي
ولا طالما اعربت اسرائيل عن خشيتها من
تمكن ايران من الحصول على اسلحه نوويه ما
جعلها تلوح مرارا بامكانيه تنفيذ هجوم على
طهران وكان رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بين
يمين نتنياهو قد اكد بهذا الخصوص انه كلما
طال الانتظار كلما اصبح الامر اكثر صعوبه
واضافنا نتنياهو بان تل ابيب انتظرت طويلا
مضيفا انه سيفعل كل ما بوسعه لمنع ايران
من الحصول على اسلحه نوويه
هذا هو من المتوقع ان يصل وزير الدفاع الى
الامريكي الى اسرائيل يوم الاربعاء المقبل
في زياره تستغرق يومين وفق ما نقله موقع
اكسيوس عن مسؤولين اسرائيليين وقال مسؤول
امريكي ان زياره اوستن تهدف الى الاشاره
لدعم الولايات المتحده لوزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي
الذي تعتبره اداره بايدن محاور موثوقا
يمكن للولايات المتحده العمل معه كما اخبر
مسؤولان امريكيا موقع اكسيوس ان الاداره
الامريكيه تريد العمل مع نتنياهو لمواجهه
ايران